Our guest is Steve Singer,
who's a professor at the university.
Uh,
ally Ola University College of law.
Steve Singer graduated
from Harvard law school,
went to the public defender service in
the district of Columbia where he was a
public defender,
uh,
for a number of years,
and then went to Louisiana where he
joined the Louisiana capital assistance
project.
And for four or five years,
excuse me,
was doing capital cases in Louisiana.
Uh,
he went to the law school,
but then when Katrina hit in 2005,
uh,
took a leave of absence and went to,
build a new public defender
office in New Orleans.
And I want to talk with Steve Today,
uh,
about both the building,
if that public defender
office and capital,
uh,
representation,
in Louisiana.
Steve,
thanks for joining us.
My pleasure.
Would you just describe to us what
was the representation for poor people
accused of crimes?
Like in New Orleans,
Orleans parish,
the city of New Orleans,
uh,
before Hurricane Katrina
hit the city in 2005.
Um,
well,
what you had was,
um,
and I,
I'm originally from Chicago and what you
had is what I would describe as a very
classic patronage system.
Um,
the judges ran the
public defender's office.
They didn't do it directly.
They were the local criminal
court judges appointed a board,
um,
of like three to five to
seven members who then ran,
who then ran up the
indigent defender office.
But the board members were selected
by the judges and they were basically
private criminal defense lawyers
who were friends with the judges and
contributed to their campaigns,
their judicial campaigns,
and got other people to contribute
to their judicial campaigns.
And so then they were on the board and
they were then able to hire their friends
and the judges friends
as public defenders,
um,
and the indigent defense system,
if you were to defy,
devise a system,
um,
that was set basically
to screw the clients.
That's what you had.
What you had was you had public defenders
who were part time and on salary.
So they were part time in
the sense that they had,
they had private criminal defense
practices and then they had a part time,
salaried position as a public defender.
And what you'd have is one or you'd
have like two or two to four public
defenders assigned per
judge per courtroom.
And they would split it up whatever they,
the way they negotiated with their judge.
So you might have one lawyer
take Mondays and Wednesdays,
the other wire take Tuesdays and
Thursdays and then maybe they'd alternate
Fridays or they do a system
where they'd have one,
they'd be on one week as a public defender
and then they'd be off for two weeks
and the next public defender would take
the next week and then the next week.
Um,
and what that meant for
the clients was since you,
since they were on salary,
it didn't matter whether they spent
two hours or two minutes on a case,
they got paid the same.
So obviously the financial incentive was
to spend as little time as possible on
your indigent public defender cases so
that you could spend more time on your
private pain cases.
Um,
and so this obviously worked to the great
detriment of the clients because they
got as little time as possible.
Um,
and,
and one of the things you have to say
about the lawyers is some of these lawyers
were,
they're not,
they weren't necessarily bad people,
but they were stuck in a really
bad system because at the time,
for example,
New Orleans,
the public school system was terrible.
So if you give,
if you give a person a choice while
you can spend the right amount,
you can spend more time on this criminal,
on this public defender indigent case,
or you can spend less time of it and you
can earn some more money and send your
kids to private school to a good,
decent school and get your
kids a decent education.
Well,
that's no kind of choice at all,
obviously for people.
Um,
so it wasn't necessarily that the
individual lawyers were bad people,
but they were stuck in a system that
really was set up to make sure that as
little time as possible with
spent on indigent defense client.
And what kind of support did they
have in terms of office space and
investigators and other things that are
deemed pretty essential to representing
people accused of crimes?
They had nothing because remember,
it's a patronage system.
And so when a patronage system,
any money,
any,
any sick,
every penny that goes somewhere other
than to a person is wasted money.
Because when you spend money on people,
they then can contribute back to your
campaigns and they can get their friends
and family and other people to
contribute to your campaigns.
But computers,
office space,
Xerox machines,
experts,
um,
investigators,
all of these other things
other than lawyers,
they don't,
they don't contribute
to judicial campaigns.
They don't send the money back
a percentage of the money back.
They don't kick it back.
So as a consequence,
they had nothing.
The judges gave them for free one room
in the courthouse because of course the
judges didn't want any money
going to office space either.
But it was like one room.
There were no private offices,
no place to meet privately with
clients or family members or witnesses.
Um,
they had four computers.
Two of which were hooked up to the
Internet by dial up connections.
They had one xerox machine that
only worked some of the time.
Um,
they never had to file any motions cause
the judges weren't require them to file
motions.
Cause again that would be wasted money
that wasn't going to people's salary,
lawyer salaries that could
then come back to the judges.
So they had,
um,
in the,
I went through the books and the year
before Katrina for approximately 12,000
cases,
um,
all told they spent in that
entire year on 12,000 cases,
they spent $9,000 on experts.
Wow.
No doing capital work,
spend $9,000 in a cup
in an hour and a half.
Right in the morning.
Now were these lawyers
also doing capital cases?
The office Yasso office
had a capital unit as well.
Umm,
those lawyers were generally full time.
Um,
but when I took over the office,
the capital lawyers,
the eight,
the National Aba standards are like
one to two capital cases per lawyer per
year.
Um,
and the Louisiana state standards
were a little bit more generous.
They were like two to four
capital cases per lawyer per year.
Um,
these lawyers had on average
around 15 to 18 capital cases.
Some were over 20 capital cases,
um,
for an individual lawyer at a time.
Let,
let me ask you this.
What was the situation after Katrina
hit in terms of people who had cases
pending in the courts?
Okay.
What happened after Katrina was the public
defender's office was funded largely
based on fines and fees on everyone
who was found guilty of any criminal
offense,
which in Louisiana
included traffic offenses.
So by and large traffic offenses,
um,
funded the public defender's office,
obviously once Katrina hit,
there were no street lights.
There were no stop signs,
there were no cars,
there were no people.
There was no police and law enforcement
doing traffic enforcement at least.
Um,
and so the funding completely dried up,
which meant the public defender's
office basically went down to,
uh,
I think one had five lawyers
in one administrative person.
And what happened to the clients was
one of the things that the pre-katrina
office did not have was they didn't
have any sort of case management system.
So they didn't know
who their clients were.
They would just walk into the courtroom
and whoever showed up in the courtroom
that day,
they represented.
So when Katrina scattered everybody,
they had no list of people.
So,
so all of the defendants just got,
they got transferred to jails throughout
Louisiana and some even to other states
throughout the south.
And they were just lost in the system.
They were nameless,
faceless,
um,
and they basically suffered miserably
because if I understand it,
the jail,
they're in New Orleans,
what's called the Orleans
parish prison flooded,
right?
So the inmates who were in there had
to be taken and distributed all across
Louisiana.
And as you said,
even some out of state.
Right.
And it was truly horrible.
It completely flooded.
And you can look back at
the pictures post Katrina,
there's the broad street overpass
that goes over the expressway,
right by the jail.
And basically you had inmates swam,
you know,
waited and got through all of the muck
to this bridge overpass where it was dry
and they generally spent from three to
seven days in basically hot blazing sun,
95 to 100 degree temperatures with no
food and no water surrounded by a bunch of
guards who had some food and some water,
but would not share it with the inmates.
Then they got transferred to um,
um,
what was called what was called
Hunt Correctional Center,
which was the classification prison where
most inmates would go before getting
sent to various prisons.
Um,
and they were all,
they were,
all of the Orleans parish inmates were
put in one big outside Penn that was
fenced in in a field.
Um,
which meant also you had,
you had juveniles,
you had young kids,
you had people charged with disorderly
conduct or drunk and or carrying an open
container and very minor offenses all
mixed in with people charged with murder,
rape,
armed robbery,
very violent people.
And you had,
you had,
you had strong men with young boys,
young kids,
and they were all mixed in,
in one big pen.
It,
and it was so dangerous.
The guards wouldn't even go in.
What they would do at feeding time was
the guards would just stand outside the
fence and they would toss over the fence,
sandwiches and bottles of water.
And of course,
what happened in that environment
is if you are big and strong,
you got food and water.
If you were weak or meek or mild mannered,
you didn't get anything
and you got beat up.
Um,
and you've got,
and you suffered.
I mean,
just,
we're talking unspeakable abuse.
And also eventually some of these inmates
then got dispersed to jails throughout
rural Louisiana.
Most of,
obviously the Orleans parish inmates.
You're talking in our African American
men and they got sent to rural Louisiana
where there were large,
largely where it's largely white.
Um,
and uh,
they suffered horrible,
horrible abuse at the hands of prison
guards at these local jail facilities.
And then also the prison guards
would let other prisoners,
uh,
other inmates,
um,
abused them,
beat them.
I mean,
literally like just
horrible being beaten up,
raped,
just horrible abuse.
And there were no records regarding these
people so that you didn't know whether
somebody perhaps should have
been released the next day,
but they could be lost out in
one of these jail somewhere.
Right,
right,
right.
There were no,
there were no records of the public
defender's office didn't have records.
Um,
and so they were really
nameless and faceless and right.
And one of the,
of course,
um,
things that was really typical of
the Louisiana justice system was,
you know,
if during Katrina,
if you were charged with
a really serious offense,
like murder or rape,
and as a consequence of
Katrina and the flood,
the evidence was lost.
Well,
if,
if after a year or two,
if you spent a year or two with no,
and just sort of moving throughout the
system and then eventually at the end
you've got released because
there was no evidence.
Well,
you kind of made out like a bandit.
On the other hand,
if you were charged with
a very minor offense,
like disorderly conduct or
an open container and we're
in for like a day or two
or five days right before Katrina
hit and you spent six months,
six or eight months in the system
getting abused and raped and beaten up,
you of course really got
the short end of the stick.
And so of course the people who were,
who were charged with very minor offenses
who we would all agree we're least
deserving of any bad treatment,
they got the worst of it.
And then of course the most violent,
dangerous people,
they sort of made out like bandits.
Tell us what you did to try to re or what
you did in fact go to restructure the
public defender office in New Orleans.
Um,
well what we did was,
uh,
um,
there were,
uh,
there was a small group of people who
sort of immediately app after the storm,
um,
sort of recognize this as an opportunity.
Um,
there was some people in the capital
field guy by the name of Ben Cone,
um,
who does capital litigation.
Um,
and then the chief judge of the court
at the time who was Calvin Johnson,
who had been a public defender and been
a good advocate even on the bench for
indigent defense.
Um,
and it decided the perk decision on
ineffective assistance of counsel due to
case loads back in the early nineties.
Um,
they wreck,
we recognize this as an opportunity.
Um,
and the biggest opportunity was
because all of the funding dried up,
the public defender's office had to lay
off all or almost all of the lawyers,
which meant because it had
been a patronage system.
Once the money dried up,
the judges no longer
had an interest in it.
And once all the lawyers were laid off,
you didn't have a vested group interested
in keeping the old system and their
jobs and keeping things the way they were.
And so we,
we took this opportunity,
um,
and basically we,
because the funding dried up,
we got some help from,
I had a friend,
a Harvard law school classmate who
was in charge of funding at the Soros
Foundation,
and we put them together
with the chief judge,
Calvin Johnson.
Um,
and we're able to leverage some emergency
funding into reforming the office.
And initially,
um,
really Calvin Johnson did a lot of the
heavy lifting in terms of getting the
judges to,
um,
the old board.
Everybody had sort of
moved and left New Orleans.
And so we got the judges to appoint a
new board that was really interested in
reform.
Um,
and uh,
um,
it had Derwyn Bunton who I think you've
spoken to and Denny Leboeuf on it.
It had somebody from two
lane and from Loyola,
Pam Metsker and Dane Seal Lino and some
local lawyers who were interested in
reform.
And then,
uh,
and I got hired on as the person on the
ground to reshape the public defender's
office because as Calvin Johnson put it,
he came,
came to me and the Dean and he
asked the Dean to loan me out from,
from Loyola law school to
fix it because he was like,
well,
Steve's the only one who has actually
been a public defender in a good
functioning public defender's office.
And who knows?
Who knows what one of these things look,
looks like.
Um,
and because I had been at,
uh,
the public defender
service in Washington DC.
And what were the,
what were the fundamental changes,
uh,
that,
that resulted
the,
the biggest change?
And I would say the absolute
most important thing and sort of,
I guess what I would call sort of the
dirty little secret about public defense
and industry indigent defense is the most
important thing is not the structural
things are sort of the,
the way things look
structurally or the system.
Um,
but the most important
thing is the people.
You have to have dedicated people as
you yourself know from doing capital
defense in the south you can have
low salaries and small resources,
but if you have really dedicated,
committed,
energetic,
smart people,
lawyers,
you can go a long way.
Of course,
good lawyers and good dedicated people
will do better in a good system and a
good structure then in a bad structure.
But if you have bad people
who aren't interested,
it doesn't matter how good a
system or structure you have,
it doesn't matter what
the funding looks like,
it won't be good.
So the first thing I quite frankly
did was I just started hiring people.
I just started hiring good young,
energetic people,
um,
to fill up all the spots.
And as I got more money,
I made sure I immediately hired
people to fill up that money.
So that it,
so that,
that,
so that the,
so that the judges and the other political
powers couldn't force some of the
old,
um,
old people back into the system.
So then when you hire people full time,
right.
That was one of the first
changes we made was we went,
we,
we immediately eliminated
the park time system.
Everyone was full time.
They had to be a full
time public defender.
We raised their salaries to,
to,
to match the district attorney's office
salaries so that they can have a good
living wage.
Um,
and we created a real salary structure
instead of this just flat part time,
$35,000 fee.
So you got more money
as you got experience.
Um,
we,
we hired investigators re I got Rick.
One of the first things I did was I was
the investigators that they had were
basically former cops just
double dipping in the system.
And so we've got rid of all of the
investigators and hired new investigators.
I hired some investigators from the public
defender's office in DC to then hire
to create like an intern
investigative program.
Um,
we hired a,
we ha we got together,
we got hired social workers,
we've got office space.
You know,
one of the biggest first things
to do was we got office space,
um,
computers,
laptop computers that they could
take into court and plug in.
They didn't have any of these basics.
Um,
there was no voicemail system.
They had no phone systems.
So we had to get a phone
system with voicemail.
We got office space with offices
for meeting with clients,
um,
and with witnesses and
with family members.
Um,
right.
They,
the way they used to take messages was
that it was just one phone line and they
would call in and people
would just pin a message,
a secretary.
We just pin a message to a message board.
Um,
so we got a real voice mail system.
just things that you would,
the normal accoutrements
of a regular law office.
And then the way you approached
representing clients,
you said before they
didn't even have files,
but now you took a
different approach as I am.
Right.
We created a case management system.
The other thing that,
that,
that was very symptomatic of
the system was in Louisiana.
Um,
you would get arrested and then your
bond would be determined at a first
appearance.
Uh,
but then the district attorney's office
had anywhere from 45 to 60 days if you
were in jail up to 150 days if
you bonded out to file charges.
And that the public defender's office
didn't represent anybody during this pre
charging time.
So it could be anywhere from two to three
months if you were in jail up to six
months,
if you were out of jail before
you ever got a public defender,
a lawyer assigned to your case.
Um,
and of course if you're after six months,
if you had an alibi or if
there was evidence it was gone.
It was long gone by that time.
If there was evidence
to prove your innocence.
Um,
so one of the first things
we started started doing,
we went full time,
a full time lawyers and to a
system of vertical representation.
What do they mean by the
time the players right away,
at first appearance.
And then by vertical you mean those
lawyer stay with the client all the way
lawyer that they would get assigned a
lawyer at first appearance and that lawyer
would stay with them throughout the case,
through all the stages of the case,
all the way till through
trial and sentencing rather
than the old system where
whatever lawyer was in
the courtroom at the time,
on the day you walked in.
That's what lawyer handled
your case that day.
Whether it was the same lawyer or a
different lawyer than you had before.
And how,
how did this was a huge
change then for New Orleans?
I mean before the lawyers
that almost acted like clerks,
they were in the courtroom
and they handled,
as you said,
whatever came in.
If lawyers who were following clients,
uh,
they're now going to different courtrooms.
So it's not quite as smooth
an operation as it had been.
Right,
right.
Of course.
Um,
the sold patronage because
the system had been,
the pre-katrina system had
been set up by the judges.
It worked extraordinarily well for the
judges because the lawyers just came to
the courtroom and lay,
as you said,
they were just like having,
they were just like the clerk or
the court reporter or the deputy,
they were just part of the accoutrements,
the judge in the courtroom
and they were just,
and they were just facility.
They were going to have a lawyer,
a name for the sixth amendment purposes
on the transcript and on the docket so
that the judge could move.
I could move the docket.
Once we went to this system
of vertical representation,
of course the lawyers were running around
from courtroom to courtroom and we're
also going to the jail
to see their clients,
which was a tremendous novelty,
um,
for the judges.
And they of course did not like the system
because it meant things took longer.
They could not get on and
off the bench just quickly.
Um,
they used to generally leave the
bench by certainly well before noon,
um,
most days unless they had a trial.
And so their reaction to that was
to try and use the contempt power,
um,
to lock people to,
to lock lawyers up to,
uh,
in order to try and force things
back the way they wanted them.
Um,
one of the first things I did,
uh,
when I started hiring lawyers is I
made a commitment to all the lawyers,
um,
that if they ever got in trouble
with any of the judges I would,
I wanted to keep,
I want it to keep all the
heat on management and off
of the individual lawyers
because the individual lawyers were the
ones standing next to the clients and
had to represent the clients.
I and the other administrators.
We had no clients.
So I wanted all of the judges in political
anger focused on management and off
of the individual lawyers.
And I want to just the
individual lawyers to say,
look,
here's Steve singers number or
here's Christine Layman's number.
They're the ones in charge,
call them.
And so as a consequence,
I would go to court whenever
anyone had to go to jail.
I made sure I was the
one who went to jail,
not the individual lawyers.
So one we could keep the individual
lawyers working on the cases and also so
that the judges wouldn't take
it out on them and the clients.
And,
and,
and you were held in contempt and taken
into custody a number of times where
you're not?
Oh,
yes,
many,
many times.
Um,
I was probably cited for contempt,
maybe somewhere between 10 and 20 times.
I'm held in contempt probably
eight to 10 times in,
locked in,
locked up and put in jail.
Um,
probably eight to 10 or 12 times.
uh,
especially during the
first year or two that I,
that I was there.
Um,
you know,
but,
but we were,
but we were ready for that.
And because of my background
in Capital Litigation,
um,
we,
we had people set up with
the right pleadings to file
and the right documents to
fought to file,
um,
that it was never for very long.
And one of the,
one of the things I had learned from,
uh,
basically from you and from Clive doing
capital work was the beauty of sort of
contempt,
um,
was I could pick,
we could pick and choose when to fight
and when nine to fight we could pick and
choose our battles.
So,
and if you and the judges were terrible,
we're terrible lawyers.
They weren't very good at litigators
because never had to really let a gate,
cause they were judges.
They got to rule.
Um,
which meant,
um,
out of all the Times I was
held in contempt and throw it,
not one ever stuck.
I never lost one of these in all the
times I was cited for contempt and held,
held in contempt,
you know,
20 times over a couple of years.
I never,
ultimately,
I never lost a single one of them because
if you pick and choose carefully where
you fight your battles,
you pick and choose on
ground that you can win
and you would take these to the appellate
courts and they would vacate the
contempts.
Right,
right.
Nate would vacate the contempt.
The procedures were,
one of the things was I just learned
a lot about the minutia of contempt
procedures and,
and,
and they were very,
they were complicated enough that the
judges could rarely follow them precisely
and correctly in order to do it right.
And you'd go and you'd win.
I mean,
like a good example of that for example,
was,
um,
in one case a lawyer was
too ill to do a trial.
So the judge made me do the trial and I
of course knew nothing about the case.
And so I told the judge I wasn't going
to do anything cause I didn't know
anything about the case.
I couldn't do anything intelligently.
And so the judge started voire
deer and had the prosecutor do,
do her voire deer and then told me,
okay,
it was my turn to do my voir dire.
And I told the judge back in chambers,
I said,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna do anything.
I'm just going to stand up and say
I'm sorry ladies and gentlemen,
I can't ask any questions cause I
don't know anything about the case.
Um,
and she and the judge,
the judge,
you know,
said,
well,
we're going to go out there and
you're going to go do voire deer.
And she ordered me out there and of course
I said it did exactly what I said and
she stopped the trial and got an excuse
the jury and then held me in contempt.
But of course she was holding me in
contempt for not asking any questions in
voir dire.
Well,
obviously that was not going to stand
up because if you don't want to,
if a lawyer doesn't want to
ask any questions in war deer,
there's nothing that says that you
can have with the lawyer has to ask
questions.
So they would,
they would fight on sort of
foolish grounds like that.
Um,
where,
where I could always win.
Well,
let me ask you this.
How would you say,
uh,
since 2005 with this new office,
with a new approach to handling cases,
uh,
where is indigent defense
the representation of poor
people accused of crimes in
New Orleans today?
I think it's each certainly vastly,
vastly improved from where
it was right before Katrina.
And certainly after Katrina,
but,
but it's much better than
it was before Katrina.
Just to give you an idea,
the total funding for the
office pre Katrina was about
1.75 to maybe $2 million,
maybe some years.
It was 2.1 million per year.
Um,
by the time I left in 2009,
it was,
it was 6.2 million.
Um,
and subsequently get went up from that.
and a lot of people have heard
in the news about recent cuts,
um,
to the public defender's budget,
but those cuts were cuts back from 9
million back to about six and a half or 7
million.
So you're still talking a good three
or four times what it was in terms of
resources,
um,
what it was pre Katrina.
And then of course the resources
are being used much better.
You have fulltime,
you have everyone at all.
Lawyers are full time,
you have no part time.
Um,
you have,
uh,
you have a good supervisory structure,
um,
with experienced lawyers in
supervisory positions in good young,
energetic lawyers being hired.
The hiring isn't just local from the
local private criminal defense bar who
contributes to judges campaigns.
Instead they hire nationally from the
top law schools all around the country.
Um,
just like a good law office would.
and uh,
um,
and they have,
they have,
they have several social workers on staff.
They have a whole,
they have a whole pre-charge unit that
deals with clients sort of in this
pre-charge phase with their bond,
um,
and getting work and getting,
getting situated back into the community.
Um,
so it's significantly better now.
Some of the progress has slowed down as
sort of state budgets with the recession
and the end of the federal stimulus.
Some of the fast advancement that we
had in the first three or four years,
things have sort of leveled off,
but I think there are still
well positioned and well
situated to take advantage
once the economy revives and state
budgets revive to take advantage and keep
progressing forward.
And one of the things I try and tell
people is I came from the public defender
service in Washington DC,
which is regarded as a great
public defenders office.
But even the public defender service in
DC wasn't what it wasn't in 1975 what it
is now.
It takes,
it takes 20,
30,
40 years to really build,
um,
a good,
a really good solid office like that.
And so I think you have to take the long
view and so there'll be some ups and
downs and they're probably in a little
bit of a leveling off or a down period
now.
But I expect that,
um,
there,
there will be well positioned to take
advantage and keep moving forward,
I think over the long haul.
I hope so.
Let,
let me ask you this professor's singer,
could we switch topics just a bit and
let me ask you to talk about a person
facing the death penalty in Louisiana.
Louisiana is still sentence
a number of people to death.
It has a number of
people on its death row.
Um,
what,
what is the quality representation in
Louisiana for people facing the death
penalty?
It is,
it is very uneven.
It's very uneven.
Uh,
the state operates,
uh,
a number of spa.
The state public defender
Board operates a number of,
um,
capital programs that are,
that are basically
regional capital programs.
There's one up in Shreveport for in Caddo
parish for sort of the northwest part
of the state.
There's one in baton rouge for
the central part of the state.
There's one down in New Orleans for the,
uh,
sort of southeast region of the state.
And then there's my old office Clive's
Clive's old office LCAC Louisiana Capital
Assistance Center.
That's sort of a jet super
regional office that goes around.
And it,
it sort of depends who you get.
There are some,
there are some very good
high quality lawyers.
Um,
certainly the people at Lcac,
um,
Richard Bark,
Christine laymen,
um,
uh,
Elizabeth Co,
the lawyers,
the lawyers that that office are really
quite good and if you're lucky enough to
get them on your case,
um,
or people are,
or them working with other
local lawyers on your case,
you can get quite good representation,
which of course as you know,
generally results in no death penalty.
Um,
if you have decent lawyer ring,
um,
and there are a number of lawyers
carry Coocha in the southeast,
the New Orleans office.
Um,
he's a very good,
good capital lawyer and he runs a pretty,
uh,
a very good shop,
um,
then,
but elsewhere in the state,
if you're not fortunate to get one,
a lawyer,
you know,
one of these really good lawyers,
if you get just a local lawyer
or one of the weaker cap,
it'll programs in the state,
then you're in,
then you're in really dire straits,
then you're in trouble.
And occasionally it
does this still happen.
I know.
And Jason Reeves case,
it was first handled by one
of these regional offices
that you mentioned and was
a hung jury at the guilt phase.
Uh,
but then the local public defender who
protested that he had so many cases,
but against his will was forced
onto the case and occurs.
That pretty much decided
the case right there.
Reeves was sentenced to death.
Uh,
does that still happen?
That still does happen and it especially
happens in it where Jason Reeves
happened in Lake Charles up
in Caddo parish in Shreveport.
Um,
sort of in the northern and
western parts of the state.
Um,
they try and keep out the,
the best lawyers who are generally not
surprisingly are in the big metropolitan
regions of Baton Rouge and,
uh,
and New Orleans,
which I did most generally
the most desirable places
to live in where there's a
lot of good legal talent.
Um,
and so that sort of thing still does
happen and there's a lot of resistance.
Um,
I would say especially
now in Caddo parish,
up in Shreveport,
up in the northwest corner of the state
to anyone from down in the New Orleans
Baton Rouge area coming up there.
And uh,
that generally determines your fate.
Yeah.
Jason Reeves was a really stark example.
They saw what happened
with good lawyering,
so they decided to change that.
And of course that changed the outcome.
And unfortunately you were saying
that still happens in some places and
particularly in Shreveport.
Yeah,
I would say particularly in
Shreveport and the north,
north,
the further north and west you get,
the closer you get to the Texas border
to Houston and Dallas outside of sort of
the western part of the state.
Um,
that's still a real problem where
they are extremely resistant,
um,
to people like the Richard Barks and,
and Christine Layman's and the
really good capital lawyers.
You know,
for example,
um,
previously one of the big death
penalty jurisdictions in the state,
one of the four big,
the four big ones where Jefferson parish,
Louisiana,
which was the white flight
area from New Orleans,
Baton Rouge,
east Baton Rouge,
um,
Caddo parish up in Shreveport
and calc issue Paris,
which was late.
Charles Jefferson was one of the worst,
um,
Lcac Richard Bark and Clive
Stafford Smith and Ben cone.
They basically made
Jefferson parish a project.
Jefferson parish now never break.
They don't bring their,
not interested in bringing
capital cases anymore.
They just don't even charge
the death penalty anymore.
The local prosecutor,
not officially,
but unofficially,
is basically said,
it's not worth it.
We'll just take the life without parole.
And they've shut down the death
penalty in one of the four biggest
jurisdictions.
So it shows you what
good lawyering can do.
Um,
but then obviously the opposite
is true elsewhere in the state.
And we've seen that in some other places
that are talked about in the materials
that people have for the course,
which is other places like Philadelphia
and places that have started capital
defender offices.
And the difference that that has
made with regard to representation,
it,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
I mean,
one of the things I'd like to say
say is that other than one volunteer,
since I've been in Louisiana since 1999,
um,
there's was one volunteer a couple of
years ago and then there was less smart in
2002 and no,
in,
you're talking,
so in the past 14,
15 years,
there have been two
executions in a deep south,
southern high death penalty state.
There've been two executions.
And the reason for that
is basically during the,
during the mid to late 1990s
and early two thousands,
you add a small,
you're talking about
basically five lawyers.
You're talking to Clive Stafford Smith,
Denny Leboeuf,
nick trying to Costa Neil Walker and
Ben comb five very committed lawyers for
working hard shutdown the death penalty
in the state of Louisiana essentially.
Well,
Jay a spa,
it's um,
it's amazing what a small
group of really smart,
talented,
committed lawyers can do.
Um,
even in a death penalty
hotbed location like,
like Louisiana.
And,
and this is both at the trial level,
but also in the appeals process that
you had.
You had,
you had three or four,
you had,
you had people like Denny Leboeuf and
Clive Stafford Smith and Neil Walker do
and myself doing trial work.
And then you had people like nick trying
to Costa and Ben Cohen and Denny doing
appeals and post conviction and that
end handling it all the way through and
that basically shut it down.
Um,
and now that a lot of
those people have left,
were worried what things are going to
look like five or 10 years down the road
that they won't look like
the last 10 or 15 years.
But it is remarkable.
Um,
I mean,
nothing makes your article on how the
death penalty is for not for the worst
crimes,
but for the worst lawyers.
True.
Then if you look at Louisiana from
the early 1990s to the present,
professor,
singer,
thank you very much for your
time and for your insights.
We are most grateful.
My pleasure.